[Music]  bella thorne shimmers in can are you  serious Munoz is crazy  after a long day by the pool with  rumored new man Scott Disick the 19 year  old actress stepped out in this metallic  Philip Lane gown with a plunging  neckline and high slits showing off her  toned legs Bella paired the out their  look with a tiara and black strappy  heels as she headed to the Cannes Film  Festival on Wednesday the famous and  loved star and her sister Danny rocked  out to blink-182 on their way to the  event  Scott nowhere to be seen interesting the  pair jetted off to Kin together on  Monday and have been packing on the PDA  ever since this is fantastic